RAY CROMWELL: Hi.
My name is Ray Cromwell, and
this is Daniel Kurka, and we
are engineers at Google who work
on ZWT, and this is GMT
Roadmap for the Future.
Now, if you were here last year
at Google I/O, there was
a session called "The History
and Future of GWT" where we
talked about creating this new
GWT steering committee that
was going to be in combination
with Google, as well some of
the top heavy hitters in
the GWT community--
people like Sencha, people like
Vaddin, like Red Hat--
to help define the roadmap for
GWT in the future in a way
that takes the community's needs
into account and not
just Google's internal needs,
which has been driving GWT
over the last couple of years.
And so what I'd like to do is
talk about what's happened
since last year when
we announced that.
So the steering committee has
met several times, and we've
had a lot of discussions, and
we've implemented some changes
to the project based on
those discussions.
So the first thing is we have
moved the GWT source code to a
Git repository now hosted
on gwt.googlesource.com.
Secondly, we've migrated to a
totally new code review system
called Gerrit, which is much
nicer than the old system we
used, and it's much more of a
pleasure to use in my opinion.
Third, if you like the GitHub
interface or you really like
working on code on GitHub,
we actually mirror
GWT to GitHub now.
So you can go to
GitHub.com/gwtproject and
track the project there.
Fourth, Red Hat has graciously
allowed to donate some
resources from their OpenShift
cloud to basically do
continuous integration
builds of GWT.
So every time there's a commit,
we'll do a build, run
tests, and we'll push
out nightly
snapshots very, very soon.
Finally, there's a totally new
home for the GWT project,
which Daniel's going to talk
about a little bit later.
So there's been some steering
committee updates as well.
So I announced last year
the members of
the steering committee.
I'm not going to go over the
complete list, but we've added
JetBrains, makers of IntelliJ
IDEA, which in my opinion is
the most awesome IDE there is.
They also make the new Android
IDE for Google.
So they are now a member of
the steering committee, so
hopefully that means really good
things in terms of GWT
support within IntelliJ IDEA,
which already actually is
pretty good.
The steering committee also met
and approved a roadmap,
which I'm going to talk about
today for GWT 2.6 and beyond.
And third, there's been a
start of what we call
decentralization.
What this means basically is
some of the pieces of this
roadmap which external people
have proposed now have
external leaders.
These are people who are going
to take responsibility for
those pieces and are going
to drive them.
For example, Vaadin is going to
drive IE 10, Windows Phone,
Microsoft Surface support.
Thomas Broyer is fully
mavenizing GWT into modules,
and he's taking over
RequestFactory support.
We also released a new
version of GWT since
last year, GWT 2.5.1.
Mostly bug fixes.
There were a couple
of improvements.
One, for example, is the Direct
Install Linker now
supports content security
policy, so you can build GWT
apps that install as Chrome
apps and extensions.
There's a couple of other things
that we've improved,
but you can see the full
set of changes online.
Let's talk about the future.
I think that's what
most people in
the room are curious.
They're worried about GWT.
They're wondering, is
it getting stale?
How is it going to evolve
in the future?
So the steering committee
met several times.
Just recently, we had our own
summit two days before I/O
where we got together
over two days,
huddled down in a bunker.
We discussed what we're going
to do going forward.
First, we defined the set of
core principles and areas of
focus that we believe that GWT
should address going forward
into the future, and we've
agreed to them by consensus.
Those are openness and
simplicity, speed,
interoperability, mobility,
reliability, and
embeddability.
First, let's talk about openness
and simplicity.
What does that mean?
I talked about this at I/O last
year, but basically, when
we complete the move to open
source, it'll make it easier
for everyone to join in and
contribute going forward.
GWT steering committee members
are now allowed as direct
committers.
This is the first time
in several years.
That means someone can actually
make a patch and just
commit directly to the
source trunk of GWT.
We have a public continuous
integration server.
So very soon, this
will be pushed
out in nightly snapshots.
So if you don't want to wait
for GWT 2.6, you can just
depend on that in your Maven
dependency file and just pick
it up nightly.
Speaking of that, we're going
to fully mavenize GWT.
So you don't just have to pick
up the whole GWT.user SDK.
Maybe you only want to use GWT
Core, GWT [? ITNN ?], and some
GWT widgets, but you don't want
RequestFactory, Factory,
or you don't want GWT RPC.
So by breaking GWT up into
smaller pieces, you can
actually speed up your compiles
and also prune your
dependency tree.
I think that's going to be more
exciting going forward
because it should enable
iterating faster.
And we're going to have regular
public steering
committee meetings, and some
of those actually will
probably be done with Hangouts
on Air so you will actually be
able to join and watch the
debate as it happens.
Simplicity.
The GWT SDK is basically
monolithic, and that means
that there's a lot of
interdependencies that makes
it hard to modularize it,
and so we're working on
disentangling those
interdependencies and breaking
them up into smaller pieces,
making everything simpler.
We're going to try to reduce
the need for GWT.XML files.
So if you're not really using
deferred bindings, and you're
just using it for declaring
inherit clauses, maybe we can
have something that's simpler.
And we're going to delete a lot
of deprecated code that's
sitting in there, that's been
there since GWT 1.1, 1.2,
stuff like Safari 2 and
3 browser support.
Anybody still care
about Safari 2?
There's a lot of stuff in there
that's cruft that we
need basically, to move forward,
we need to go back
and remove some stuff that's
holding us down, that's
technical debt.
Speed.
So GWT has always been
about speed.
We've always cared a lot about
download speed, latency, code
size, execution speed.
But we haven't really talked
a lot about compile speed.
I know a lot of people have
complained in the past about
the compiler in terms
of its speed.
So minimally, we're looking at
doubling the speed of the
compiler and also improving the
speed of Super Dev Mode
Refresh so it becomes a lot
more viable as a real
replacement for Dev Mode if
you should so choose.
And we're going to continue
to improve on code size,
especially as we talk about
mobile, including improving
the CodeSplitter to make it a
lot simpler to use, not so
much of a black art to find
the right places to insert
your split points.
GWT was created actually even
before V8, and so those were
the Dark Ages of browsers.
And so we've heard some talk
about the fact that JITs in
browsers with JavaScript have
evolved so much that the
compiler might be outputting
code that's suboptimal for
some of the very newest
browsers.
So we need to actually look at
that, figure out what we need
to change to actually fully
leverage the newest browsers,
especially on mobile.
And just to complete the
performance and speed story,
we need some better tools for
profiling and spotting
performance problems
in GWT apps.
Interoperability.
GWT has always had an
interoperability story, which
is the JavaScript native
interface.
I'm sure everybody who has been
using GWT for awhile has
probably written one or
two over the years.
But if you want to wrap a
JavaScript library that has a
few hundred methods,
you end up writing
a lot of JSNI methods.
It's just a lot of boilerplate
just to consume an API.
And we want to make that
a lot more automatic.
We think you should just be able
to drop a library in, and
there should be some tool to
just automatically generate
overlay types by just looking
at the JavaScript itself.
That's going to entail improving
integration and
support with the Closure
Compiler, which does a good
job at type inferencing, as
well as accomplishing the
first two items will allow
us to support hybrid apps
efficiently.
That means maybe you've got 80%
GWT code and you've got
some web designers who want to
sprinkle in a little bit of
JavaScript.
It should be easy to do cross
calls between the two without
a lot of effort.
Likewise, maybe someone's got
a JavaScript app that's 80%
JavaScript, but there's some
Java library out there they
want to consume.
And so the JavaScript programmer
should be able to
just make a call directly to
Java code, and it should be
really easy and painless
to do that.
But I think the thing that
people are going to be most
excited about is a commitment to
full Java 7 and 8 support.
So we haven't really announced
it yet, but there's actually a
patch about to land in GWT very,
very soon that fully
enables Java 7.
That means all the newest Java
7 language features will
basically be available in GWT
including try-with-resources,
multi-catch, diamond operator,
you name it.
And so it's been a long time
since we upgraded the language
support, and now we're finally
starting to do that.
But the real thing that I think
people are waiting for
is lambdas in Java 8.
And so the minute that Oracle
launches Java 8 and there's a
JDT library that's released that
supports parsing Java 8
source code, we're going to jump
right on integrating that
into GWT so you can start using
closures or lambdas for
all of those event erasing
[INAUDIBLE] based APIs.
Reliability.
If you've been looking at the
Issue Tracker over the years,
you might have noticed it's kind
of stale, doesn't seem to
get much traction.
You file bugs, no one pays
attention to them.
I talked about this last year
at I/O, but we really
apologize for that.
Some of it's basically that we
have our own internal issue
tracker, and as more and more
GWT Apps were created inside
Google from really important
teams like AdWords or at the
other GWT presentation
earlier, Wallet.
They file bugs on us too, and
we tend to fix the ones that
are first from the internal
Google apps, and then we look
at the external repo.
And it turns out external
repo got really stale.
So the steering committee
members are basically going
through bug by bug in the
external repository and
closing issues that
are really stale--
for example, Safari 2
or 3, or IE 6 bugs.
And bugs that have a lot of
votes, we're actually going to
start looking at fixing
them and closing them.
We're also going to try to
improve GWT unit testing to
make it a lot less painful.
A lot of people don't bother
writing GWT test cases just
because invoking them is really
slow, and they tend to
be flaky sometimes, especially
in browsers like IE 6 and 7.
So we're looking at improving
that experience and making
round tripping unit tests with
GWT and Super Dev Mode to be a
much more pleasurable experience
in the future.
But really, just to confess
over the years in terms of
what breaks the GWT build and
what breaks GWT apps, 99% of
the time, it's IE 6 and 7.
Someone commits a change to GWT,
Unit Test Suite runs, the
breakage is always
in some IE 6 or 7
class out there somewhere.
So a big part of this
is for GWT 3.0--
not next release but the
release after that--
we're going to remove IE 6 and 7
support finally and bury it.
It's like a vampire.
It seems like you can't kill
it, but we're going to try.
[APPLAUSE]
RAY CROMWELL: And this will
remove a huge technical debt.
For example, when Daniel talks
about mobile later, it's
really hard to design an
efficient mobile widget API if
you have to support IE
6 Layout Engine.
Embeddability.
So some people actually build
tools like Red Hat, Vaadin,
Sencha, and they tend
to actually need to
use pieces of GWT.
Maybe you don't want to use the
whole GWT compiler, but
you want to basically use the
part that can make parse some
Java and hand you back an AST
of the source, and maybe you
want to filter over the source
and do some transformations.
Maybe you want to do static
analysis tools,
look for bad code.
And so we're going to start
trying to break it up a little
bit and add more public APIs
so you can just pull out a
piece of GWT and reuse
it or embed it in
another tool chain.
So now we come to mobile, which
I think is the most
important part of this
presentation.
Maybe it's the most exciting
thing yet.
So as you may have heard over
the years, mobile has been
becoming increasingly
important.
It really is the most
important thing now.
For some key metrics on some
applications, mobile usage has
surpassed desktop usage.
But GWT created in the era of
desktop apps back in 2006, and
so there wasn't a lot of thought
back then given to
actually designing
it to efficiently
support mobile apps.
It turns out, actually, it is
pretty good for building
mobile apps, which it has some
core fundamentals that enable
that, and Daniel's going to
talk about that later.
But some of the key things we
decided for the roadmap on the
steering committee is to support
modern mobile web
browsers directly, to create
a set and support a set of
mobile optimized widgets so you
don't have to worry about
jankiness, to integrate with
application life cycle and on
and offline detection on mobile
devices, and to support
package app deployment.
So if you want to put a GWT app
in an App Store, it should
be really easy to do so.
And with that, I'd like to turn
it over to Daniel Kurka,
author of the excellent and
fabulous MGWT Library if
you've never seen it, and newly
minted Google employee
and member of the GWT team.
[APPLAUSE]
DANIEL KURKA: Hello, everyone.
I want to talk about GWT and
mobile, and as it turns out,
performance on mobile is really
important because in
performance, we do have slow
CPUs, we do have slow network
connections, and we're
running on battery.
So even if we were getting
faster CPUs, we can't really
use them because we're
just going to
drain the user's battery.
And GWT, as it turns out, is
in a quite unique position
when it comes to performance
because the GWT compiler just
doesn't know about just your
JavaScript, it knows about all
your resources and
can optimize on
all of them at once.
If you want to get the basic
things on web performance,
there's a really good talk from
Ilya Grigorik, one of our
colleagues at Google.
It's three hours long.
It covers all the basics there,
so I encourage you to
check that out.
There's a link on the slides.
To me, there are different
kinds of performances.
There's startup performance,
there's runtime, and of
course, there's resource
usage.
So let's drill into
all of these.
Startup on mobile, start upon
any browser drills down to you
have to download your resources,
you have to parse
them, and you have
to execute them.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DANIEL KURKA: What's
happening?
RAY CROMWELL: We're like
the Academy Awards.
DANIEL KURKA: Where was I?
Well, startup performance on
mobile drills down to you have
to download your resources, you
have to parse them, and
you have to execute them.
The GWT compiler is really good
at helping you with those
kinds of things.
So let's take a look into
different things the GWT
compiler is really good at.
So if you're transferring text
resources such as HTML, CSS,
or JavaScript, you should be
transferring them as gzipped.
This is basically like
a free lunch.
And with GWT, that's
very easy.
You're just going to zip up
those compiler outputs
upfront, put them in your WAR
Directory, deploy a small
servlet filter over that, and
if the client supports gzip,
you're going to use the
gzipped version.
So you're not going to even pack
the service CPU for that.
Another thing that's pretty
important in web performance
is not to have blocking script
tags because as soon as a
parser hits a blocking script
tag, the browser has to go
fetch that script, parse
it, and execute it.
And after that, it can just
continue browsing.
So imagine doing that on a
really slow network connection
with lots of different
script tags.
But with GWT, you're just going
to have one script tag,
and the GWT compiler actually
controls the [? boot step ?]
process and is really
good at doing this.
The other thing you need to
get right for mobile, you
don't want to re-download
resources you've once
downloaded before.
So you need to set your HTTP
headers right for caching.
And with GWT, again, that's
very straightforward.
You don't need to think about
individual resources and how
to cache them.
You basically get two
kinds of resources.
You do have a nocache.js file,
which you won't cache for
long, and you do have a cache.js
or cache.html file,
which you can cache forever.
On mobile, the user's going to
have a flaky connection, so
sometimes, they're going
to be offline.
So you need to be looking to
actually using app cache for
solving that so this application
still works even
if a user doesn't have
connectivity.
People are actually writing
articles on how hard it is to
use App Cache and to deploy
that properly.
But again, with GWT, because the
compiler knows all about
your resources, it can just help
you write that manifest
file for you.
Just going to use a custom
linker and get that manifest
file ready, so there's just one
line in your GWT XML file.
Then again, the GWT compiler
is really good
at minifying resources.
We all know it's really good at
JavaScript, but what's not
so well known, it's
really good at CSS
and images as well.
So if you have a big library
like MGWT with lots of
different widgets, but you're
only using 20% of those
widgets, the compiler removes
all the other JavaScript but
the CSS as well.
This also applies to images.
Let's say you have a button with
a small image on there.
It also removes that image if
you're not using the button,
so that's pretty important
as well.
And the GWT compiler has been
doing that since 2007,
basically, inlining
and spriting.
This actually solves the amount
of HTTP requests you
have to do back to the server.
If you're spriting images,
you're just going to do one
HTTP request.
If you're inlining them, you
don't do any HTTP requests
whatsoever.
Many of you are probably
writing really big GWT
applications.
And for mobile, this is kind of
a problem because you don't
want to ship a megabyte of
JavaScript to a mobile device
and wait for the slow network
connection to actually
download that.
So within GWT, we do have a
notion of actually shipping a
small part of the application
first while the rest is
downloading in the background.
We call that code splitting.
And with GWT, that's very easy
and straightforward to use.
You just do a GWT.runAsync
call, and the compiler
actually takes care
of splitting up
that output for you.
The other thing you want to be
doing is you want batch your
data calls.
So if your application boots
up, there are going to be
several presenters on the
screen, and they're all going
to need data.
If they are all going to do an
HTTP request back to the
server, you're not going to have
enough TCP connections
back to the server.
So what you actually want to be
doing, you want to be using
a command pattern and batching
those requests into lists of
commands, sending them off to
the server, and getting a list
of responses back and
dispatching them back to your
presenters.
And again, with
Schedule.scheduleFinally in
GWT, this is very
easy to achieve.
So this is about downloading.
Once you've downloaded
everything, you still need to
parse everything, and you
need to execute it.
And please keep in mind, parsing
JavaScript actually
blocks the UI, so you don't want
to be parsing megabytes
of JavaScript upfront.
And all the resources you're
going to need, they have to be
downloaded and parsed
before you can
actually do initial painting.
This is quite important
as well.
So your HTML is going to be
parsed into the DOM, your CSS
is going to be parsed into the
CSS tree, and now the browser
actually has to match those two
trees into one, which is
called the render tree.
The next step, it has to lay out
that render tree and then
paint the render tree
to the screen.
And here's some common
performance pitfalls.
So if you've got to fill a
huge, humongous DOM, that
matching process becomes
incredibly slow, so you need
to be careful about how many
DOM elements you're using.
But luckily with the GWT
compiler, we can actually
build mobile optimized widgets
which just take
care of that for you.
The other thing you want to
have, you want to have good
selected performance matching.
So if the browser is matching
those two trees into one, you
want to be careful about how
deeply your CSS selectors are
actually nested.
But as it turns out, CssResource
is really good at
keeping those selectors unique,
so you don't need to
use deeply nested selectors if
you're using CssResource.
So we've downloaded the
application, it's running, but
people still think that HTML5
applications have to feel
somewhat sluggish on a phone.
They have to be somewhat
slower than native
applications can be.
But if you pay attention on how
the browser works, and if
you do your work thoroughly,
you can be as fast or even
faster as native applications
can be.
And there are two main points I
actually want to point out.
I call them native layout
and native animations.
So what do I mean by
native layout?
Well, you should be never
doing your layout in
JavaScript.
You should be doing all your
layout in native code.
That's a very strange statement
to make as a web
developer because frankly, we
are never writing native code.
Well, in a way we are because
if you do all your layout in
CSS, the layout is actually
executed by the layout engine,
and this means it's actually
executed by native code, so
this is really fast.
And on mobile phones, you've
got those really advanced
browsers so you can actually
do that using the
flexible box model.
If you don't know about the
flexible box model, there's a
really good talk from
last year's
I/O from Eric Bidelmann.
You might want to
check that out.
And again, that's a really good
case of what we can do
with GWT for mobile
optimized widgets.
The other thing you want to
do right is animations.
Animations should be
feeling on a phone
really slick and fast.
So some JavaScript libraries
do animations like this.
Let's say they want to move
a Div from here to there.
And what they're doing is
they're firing off a timer
which fires every 60
milliseconds to get that 60
FPS rate, and then they're
updating the
position top and left.
What's happening here is they're
basically telling the
browser, move it one
pixel, move it one
pixel, move it one pixel.
So what the browser does
underneath, it updates the DOM
that updates the render tree.
The render tree needs
to be layouted and
drawn to the screen.
So what if you actually
tell the browser what
you want to be doing?
I want to move that Div from
here to there in 300
milliseconds with a certain
timing curve.
Then the browser can actually
find a decent way
of executing that.
And as it turns out, what
happens then this if you do a
whole animation in CSS, the
browser actually draws a
picture of the region you want
to move, uploads that to the
GPU, and moves that on the GPU
so you're not using any CPU
whatsoever.
And this is really, really fast
and doesn't consume any
real battery whatsoever.
And again, this is something
we can pack
into the GWT compiler.
So GWT has been designed from
the ground up to be really,
really performant.
The GWT team always cared deeply
about performance.
They went to great lengths to
actually optimize the compiler
to be as performant as possible
because in Google
production, we care deeply
about performance.
And as it turns out, mobile
exactly needs that
performance.
So using GWT for writing mobile
applications is an
actual no-brainer.
But with GWT on mobile, we
can actually do more.
You can take today your well
written GWT application and
run that on any modern phone
or tablet using PhoneGap.
And if you stick to good
practices with your CSS, you
can actually achieve a native
look and feel just fine.
But as a web application,
we can actually do more.
We can use all the same cool
APIs that the native
developers are using,
but we can use
them through web standards.
So this means that you can
actually use the same code for
your phone, your tablet, and
your desktop application.
In MVP terms, this means you can
have the same presenter,
you can have the same models,
the same RPC, the same almost
everything--
despite having different views
because you want to have
different views on a phone
up to the desktop--
you're going to have different
navigation
between those views.
So if you want to do that today,
you can do that using
MGWT, and we've got lots of
mobile optimized widgets in
there which we're going
to start to improve in
GWT proper with 3.0.
And you can use PhoneGap
by using GWT PhoneGap.
And actually, I want to show you
some of that stuff running
on different devices.
So this is a GWT application
running on an iPhone.
So notice what happens
if I hit Reload.
This is how long it actually
takes to start up such an
application.
This is not a small
application, so
this is quite big.
You can see the difference
in layouting in such an
application.
If I actually go ahead and turn
the phone, you can see--
just a second.
Sorry about that.
Let's actually go first
to full screen.
So this is the same application
just pushed to the
home screen.
So you can do different
animations in here,
like we just said.
Those animations are actually
done with CSS.
This is why they behave
slick and fast.
So you do all kinds of animation
that you like to do,
slide it in between.
But you can actually put some
time into it and build
different mobile widgets
as well.
So you can build something like
a carousel where you have
different scrolling widgets
which scroll fine like this,
and they can even be scrolled
individually.
You can even build lists with
headers that push themselves
out at the top, which
behave really fast.
You can see that if I turn my
finger here, how fast that is
actually working.
But since we are GWT, we can use
the compiler to actually
swap out the CSS for
different devices.
You can take the same
application that I've just
shown you, launch that on an
Android phone, and it looks
like an Android application
because we can just introduce
a compiler permutation here
and write different CSS.
So none of the CSS that's there
to power the style looks
of that application
is inside that
application, and vice versa.
That really makes a huge
difference in size.
So on Android, you're going to
have the same widgets that do
the same stuff just fine.
But this gets even cooler when
you get to the third platform
and take an Android application
with different
styling that works
fine on an iPad.
So you're going to have the same
widgets, you're going to
lay out the application a little
bit different, you're
going to have different MVPs
running, of course.
But it just behaves fine like
you would expect it to be.
We can even continue doing that
just like that, and pull
on an Android tablet
just fine.
So you can do things like put
Refresh widgets really easy
and really slick.
But this is all just Web UI.
What if we actually wanted
to go and access native
functionality on a device?
Well, we can do that
using PhoneGap.
This is a GWT application
running
inside a PhoneGap container.
So as a web application, I can't
read the accelerometer.
So if I want to do that, I
actually need that PhoneGap
container to run.
But as soon as I hit Start, I'm
asking PhoneGap to give me
the values of the
accelerometer.
You can see as I turn my phone,
the values are just
changing with it.
I can even get one
step further and
actually use the camera.
So this is still the GWT
application running here, but
as soon as I hit that button
down here, we're actually
changing to a native view which
invokes the camera.
I can take a picture and put
that picture back into the
JavaScript application.
So let me do that.
I'll pick up the phone.
So I should probably
do it like this.
Everyone smile.
Take that picture.
So here's the picture.
This is still inside
a native view.
And we can just hit Use-- that's
a German phone, so
[GERMAN]
is "Use" in German--
and actually dispatch that
picture back into
JavaScript and there.
Oh, it's not a nice one,
but there it is.
So this is how we can
actually do device
integration on a phone.
But since this is a GWT
application, we can actually
tell it to run offline
just fine.
Remember I said we can
just produce the
manifest file for you.
So I just put the phone in
flight mode so it doesn't have
any real connection
whatsoever.
So I can now take that GWT
application just fine, hit
Reload, and it still works.
I actually want to talk quickly
about gwtproject.org.
So this has been mobile.
There's one other thing which
we wanted to address.
Since GWT is now a community
owned project, we wanted to
have a home for all the
GWT-related stuff out there.
So this used to be
developers.google.com, which
was a problem because only
Google employees could do
anything to it.
So we thought about this.
Since we are an open source
project, we wanted to be the
website and the documentation
open source as well so anyone
can actually contribute to the
website just fine or the
documentation.
And so we figured Markdown these
days is quite popular,
and we thought maybe we
can build a whole
page based on Markdown.
And because we don't want to put
Markdown on a web server,
we want to do out of HTML,
CSS, and JavaScript.
So we figured we're just going
to write a maven plugin to
actually convert that Markdown
to a nice looking home page.
So today, you can contribute
to the website and the
documentation using the same
review process, the same
guidelines, that we use for
GWT proper source code.
So if you want to do something
cool to the home page, if you
just want to fix a bug inside
the documentation, you can
just do that.
If you want to do something
cool, write an article or
anything else, just talk to us
and we'll figure it out.
So if you want to do that,
what do you do?
Well, you go ahead and clone
the Git repository.
Then you take a look at the
Markdown and fix the docs or
write something yourself.
If you want to take a look at
how it actually looks, you can
just do a local MVN Clean
Install, and you can take a
look at target/generated-site,
and the whole site will be
generated in that
folder for you.
And if you think what you've
been doing is great and other
people could benefit from this,
you're just going to do
a Commit and push that commit
off to us for review.
And if you get a positive
review, we automatically push
that to the new home page.
It's going to be live
on the page.
If you want to know more about
this, take a look at
gwtproject.org/makinggwtbetter,
and this is
how it actually looks.
RAY CROMWELL: By the way,
the website is now
actually a GWT app.
DANIEL KURKA: Ray is right.
The website is actually
a GWT application.
RAY CROMWELL: It actually
uses GWT now.
So the big question you might
have is when is all
this going to happen?
Steering committee got
together trying
to decide on a schedule.
We're going to adopt a tick-tock
model like Intel.
Every six months, we're going
to have minor revision.
Every year, major revision.
So quarter four 2013 this year,
look for GWT 2.6, which
would be a minor update.
The dot, dot, dot, there could
be some other minor releases
in between.
Then for I/O 2014, another six
months later, look for GWT
3.0, which should have all the
goodies that we've discussed
here today.
So before I go to questions, I
want to shout out some thanks.
First of all, I'd like to thank
the steering committee
for meeting for many, many hours
over the past year to
hash all this out.
Thanks to Red Hat.
Mike Brock is over there.
He's a steering committee
member.
Thanks, Mike, for providing the
build bot and OpenShift
resources on the Red Hat cloud
for hosting all this stuff.
Thanks to Vaadin and
Julienne Dramaix--
I hope that's how you
pronounce it-- of
the GWTQuery project.
GWTQuery is actually being
used in the new
gwtproject.org, and he worked
with Daniel as well as Vaadin
to actually make the site
look a lot better
and freshen it up.
I also would like to extend
a special thanks to Thomas
Broyer if no one knows who he
is or has been following the
GWT Contributors News Group.
He's been our largest GWT
contributor over the last
couple of years.
He's fixed hundreds of bugs.
He's probably actually
fixed more bugs than
the GWT team combined.
And so I really wanted him to
be at I/O this year but he
couldn't make it, so hopefully
he's watching.
And so I'd just like to extend
a special thanks towards
Thomas for all his hard
work over the years.
DANIEL KURKA: Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
RAY CROMWELL: So in summary,
what's the future of GWT?
I think it's pretty bright, but
to summarize it up, faster
development in an open setting
for the modern and mobile web
with fewer surprises, more
compatibility with Java, and
easier interoperability with the
rest of the non-GWT world.
Thanks very much.
And with that, I'll take the
remaining questions.
We have about six and
a half minutes.
DANIEL KURKA: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned
improved interactions between
Java and JavaScript.
Can you a little bit
expand on that?
I'm particularly interested in
basically building a reusable
library using GWT but that
can be used uniquely from
JavaScript without having--
RAY CROMWELL: Yeah.
So I am the original author of
the GWT Exporter Project,
which basically, you put
annotations on methods like At
Export and it exports
a public API.
The code's kind of bloated,
and it doesn't actually
generate a code that's easy for
JavaScript programmers to
eyeball and actually
figure out how they
should be calling it.
We're starting to actually use
GWT Exporter a lot within
Google itself, and I'm putting
in a lot of time and resources
to rewriting it essentially to
make it much more idiomatic in
terms of the output looking
really like a handwritten
JavaScript library and having
less bloat and overhead.
But there'll be more information
on the GWT
steering mailing list
and in the roadmap.
We're going to actually release
the detailed roadmap
very, very soon.
It's a G Drive Document.
You'll be able to look at it.
Next?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is Sebastian.
In my company, I actually use
GWT in enterprise solutions,
and it's always been
a bit of a scary
moment, especially recently.
We don't have really
support for GWT.
As you mentioned yourself,
Google was prioritizing the
internal box instead
of the public box.
Is there any kind of--
RAY CROMWELL: External
support?
AUDIENCE: External support
that can be purchased.
RAY CROMWELL: If you talk to
Mike Brock right over there on
the far right, I know Red Hat
actually does some support, as
well as Vaadin.
If you visit vaadin.com, they
provide official support for
GWT externally.
And so if you actually have a
super high priority thing that
you need fixed, they actually
will do it.
And behind you in
line is Navigo.
They might actually be able to
help you out if you have some
issues, too.
But we are going to pay
attention, community wide,
more attention to the
issue tracker.
And since we can accept bug
fixes much easier, instead of
people putting a patch into the
issue tracker and it sits
there for two years and
no one looks at it.
Now actually, it will go
immediately into the code
review system, everyone gets
emailed, someone looks at it,
they actually just click
a button that says
it looks OK to me.
Then you get an OK, you
click a button, and
you commit it yourself.
And poof, it's fixed
and it's in.
DANIEL KURKA: If you paid
attention to the issue tracker
in the last month, we actually
brought the amount of issues
down quite a bit.
RAY CROMWELL: We closed
about half the
issues in Issue Tracker.
AUDIENCE: Just to add on my
question, do we have a clear
picture on the commitment
of Google in GWT?
We know currently, some Google
employees are committing to
GWT, but do you have more
commitment from Google?
RAY CROMWELL: Google
is continuing
to develop new apps.
There are actually internal apps
as we speak, not old ones
but new ones actually
are being created
every day using GWT.
So it's not being deprecated
or dropped.
We're not dropping support for
it, if that's your question.
Let me go to the next person
before we run out of time.
You can talk to me afterwards.
AUDIENCE: I've been following
GWT for awhile.
I just wondered how does the
future of GWT fit in with the
future of Dart?
RAY CROMWELL: That's a question
that's been asked
many, many times.
I think it's orthogonal.
In other words, Dart is not
replacing GWT or vice versa.
Google is a large company.
We have many, many languages.
Some teams choose Dart, some
teams choose GWT, some choose
Closure Compiler.
Some people write stuff
in JQuery, actually,
internally at Google.
YouTube is based on Python.
Some teams build their apps in
Go on the back end, some Java.
There's no mandate from above.
Larry doesn't say everyone has
to write everything in a
certain language.
Basically, people choose based
on what they're interested in.
AUDIENCE: So do you think
is GWT ever going to
compile into Dart?
RAY CROMWELL: I don't know.
Talk to me afterwards,
and we can speculate.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm Dennis.
Two questions, real
quick ones.
You mentioned the slides
at the beginning.
Are those available, because I
know this one isn't filmed.
You didn't video this one.
DANIEL KURKA: It's
actually filmed.
AUDIENCE: Oh, it is?
RAY CROMWELL: It will be
available on YouTube.
We also will make the
slides available.
The Google website, the new
gwtproject.org, will have a
public G Drive folder associated
with it, and there
will be lots of documents we'll
be dropping in there,
presentations, plus the steering
committee meeting
minutes, plus the roadmap,
the detailed roadmap.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Second question, is there
someone, like you guys or
someone available to talk
about GWT offline?
Because I had some bugs in
some of my GWT that I was
hoping to just talk to you
about here at Google I/O?
But I noticed there's no
sandboxes out there for GWT.
DANIEL KURKA: We can
talk afterwards.
RAY CROMWELL: You can talk to
him afterwards, right after.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thanks.
RAY CROMWELL: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Can you say anything about the
future of GWT Designer or
potentially other tools for
developing GWT applications?
RAY CROMWELL: I actually don't
know anything about that
because that's actually run
by a different team.
That's run by Rajeev Dayal,
who is in New York, and I
think he deals with the team.
John, are they in partly Russia,
the team behind the
[? GPE ?] plugin?
MALE SPEAKER: Last I knew,
it [? wasn't. ?]
RAY CROMWELL: They have a
different reporting structure
within Google, so they
actually don't
report to the GWT team.
It's almost like a
separate product.
So I would actually
have to ask them.
But maybe send a message to
Contributors News Group, and I
can get Rajeev to respond to
you, who runs the stuff.
AUDIENCE: Really quick following
question if there is
plans to integrate Java and
JavaScript more, and is there
any plan to put annotations on
the produced JavaScript so
that closure might be able
to better process
some things or optimize?
RAY CROMWELL: Yes.
We actually already have
something like that
internally, and that's more
what I mean about
interoperability.
The idea basically is that
GWT can now output JSDoc
annotations, closurized code
with @constructor and @type
annotations.
So when you actually consume it
from Closure Code, you'll
get type checking, static
type checking enclosure.
IntelliJ IDEA will actually
allow you
step through the code.
The reverse is also true.
Eventually, you'll be able to
point GWT to closurized code,
and it will understand the
closure annotations, and you
won't have to actually write
a JSNI method to
call closure code.
It will synthesize on the fly
an actual overlay type based
on the type information that's
present in the JSDoc.
And that's what I meant about
better interoperability
between the two languages.
I've got 38 seconds left.
Anybody got one more question?
DANIEL KURKA: No time.
This is actually counting up.
RAY CROMWELL: Oh, sorry.
I'm actually over.
I went negative.
But if you have any other
questions for me, you can see
me outside the room.
You can talk to me or Daniel.
Thank you very much for
coming and see you
guys maybe next year.